PROTEST WERE ALREADY SICK AND
THEREFORE COULD SPREAD THE
DISEASE.
TUCKER.
>> Tucker: INTERESTING.
TRACE THANKS A LOT FOR THAT.
>> SURE.
>> Tucker: NEW YORK CITY HAS
HIRED A THOUSAND CONTRACT
TRACERS.
THEIR JOB IS TO TRACK THE SPREAD
OF CORONAVIRUS.
THEY ARE EXPENSIVE.
THEY ARE BEING PAID AN ANNUAL
SALARY OF $60,000 APIECE,
$5 MILLION FROM U.S. TAXPAYERS
EVERY MONTH.
THE IDEA IS THEY WILL PREVENT A
SECOND OUTBREAK AND THEREFORE, A
SECOND LOCKED DOWN IN NEW YORK.
BUT THEY ARE NOT EVEN TRYING.
BY THE WAY THE CONCERN FROM DAY
ONE IS THIS NEW COURSE OF
EMPLOYEES WILL BE USED FOR
POLITICAL PURPOSES, AND THEY
ALREADY ARE.
TRACERS HAVE BEEN TOLD NOT TO
ASK WHETHER PEOPLE INFECTED WITH
THE CORONAVIRUS RECENTLY
ATTENDED "BLACK LIVES MATTER"
PROTESTS.
WHY IS THAT?
JOINING US TONIGHT THE FOX
MEDICAL CONTRIBUTOR
DR. MARC SIEGEL.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
WHAT IS THIS ABOUT?
>> TUCKER, WHEN IT COMES TO
PUBLIC HEALTH, POLITICIANS
UNDERMINED THEIR CREDIBILITY BY
HAVING DIFFERENT STANDARDS FOR
DIFFERENT PEOPLE.
I WILL GIVE YOU TWO EXAMPLES.
WHEN YOU ALREADY TALKED ABOUT.
FIRST IS SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
THE OTHER IS CONTACT TRACING.
SOCIAL DISTANCING
GOVERNOR WHITMER A HUGE
PROPONENT OF SOCIAL DISTANCING
EXCEPT WHEN SHE WENT ELBOW TO
ELBOW WITH THE PROTESTERS.
WHEN ONE OF THE REPRESENTATIVE
STATE REPRESENTATIVES FROM
GRAND RAPIDS SAID YOU KNOW WHAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING IS CRITICAL
UNLESS YOU HAVE A GREAT PHOTO
UP.
HERE IN NEW YORK STATE,
GOVERNOR CUOMO USES THE STICK
AND THE CARROT.
THIS MORNING TO STICK, NEW YORK
WE MAY LOCK YOU DOWN AGAIN.
IF YOU DON’T CUT IT OUT.
THIS AFTERNOON HE USED THE
CARROT, PLACES WHERE HE
MENTIONED UP TO 25 PEOPLE CAN
GATHER.
THE CARROT AND A STICK.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE CONTACT
TRACING YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT,
THIS IS DEEPLY DISTURBING,
TUCKER.
BECAUSE IT’S AT THE HEART OF
PUBLIC HEALTH.
BUT A SPOKESPERSON FOR
MAYOR de BLASIO SAID THE
CONTACT TRACING IN THE CITY WILL
NOT BE PROACTIVE.
PROACTIVE ABOUT WHETHER YOU
ATTENDED A PROTEST OR NOT.
BUT PROACTIVITY IS THE VERY
ESSENCE OF CONTACT TRACING.
LET ME GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE.
DOWN IN CAPE MAY OVER THE
MEMORIAL DAY WEEKEND, THERE WAS
A PARTY.
IT WAS A SUPER-SPREADER THERE.
THE LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICIALS ZOOMED IN AND CHECKED
EVERYBODY AT THE PARTY.
THEY FOUND OUT WHO HAD IT, WHO
WAS CONTACTED BY THEM, THEY
ISOLATED THEM AND PREVENTED
FURTHER SPREAD.
OBVIOUSLY THAT APPLIES TO THE
PROTESTERS AND OBVIOUSLY, THAT
IS WHAT NEW YORK CITY
CONTRACT TRACING SHOULD BE IS
BEING PROACTIVE AND WERE YOU IN
THAT CROWD, WHAT DID YOU DO IN
THAT CROWD, WHO WERE YOU WITHIN
THAT CROWD?
TUCKER, MY PRESCRIPTION FOR
TONIGHT INSTEAD OF POLITICIANS
MAKING THESE DECISIONS, WHY
DON’T WE TURN TO PHYSICIANS?
TUCKER.
>> Tucker: THAT IS THE
QUESTION YOU HAVE ASKED AND